Cette balle ne va jamais atterrir par terre
Ca a raté ahah
Les amis aujourd'hui on va parler on va apprendre des choses on va parlé d'un truc que j'aime énormément
Qui s'appelle...
Souvenez vous il y a  quelques mois on avait sous forme de jeu pu parler de la théorie des jeux voilà c'est
Un jeu qui a été développe par Nicky Case
En gros Nicky Case c'est un mec qui aime bien à travers ces jeux apprend des choses aux gens il fait de la sociologie essentiellement!
Aujourd'hui on va en savoir plus sur l'effet de groupe. Qui n'a jamais été un gros connard au milieu d'un groupe? Parce que il est influencé
voyez ce que je veux dire
Ou à l'inverse qui n'a jamais été influencé positivement par son groupe?! Bref, bienvenue sur son autre jeu qui s'appelle la sagesse et ou folie des
foules et cela va être très intéressant moi en tout cas c'est un
sujet que j'aime bien encore plus que la théorie des jeux même! On y va ça a été traduit par Clem Keirua merci Clem Keirua, on t'adore tous.. (lol)
C'est faux (évidemment!)
Sir Isaac Newton était plutôt sûr d'être un malin après tout avec l'invention du calcul différentiel et la
théorie de la gravité il aurait dû être assez intelligent pour des investissements financiers non? Pour faire court il a perdu 4 millions six cent
mille dollars dans la folie spéculative nationale appelée la bulle de la mer du sud de
1720 comme il l'a dit ensuite je peux calculer le mouvement des corps célestes! Mais pas la folie du peuple.  Et oui! Tu peux prévoir
des maths sauf que le comportement des gens c'est très complexe et très difficile à prévoir
bien sûr ce n'est pas la seule fois où les marchés institutions ou des démocraties ce sont des traqués c'est la folie des foules
et pourtant au moment où on perd foi en l'humanité on trouve des gens qui s'organisent pour se porter secours lors des ouragans des communautés
qui trouve des solutions des gens qui combattent pour un monde meilleur!
a contrario ça, cela s'appelle la sagesse des foules ça montre quand même groupe peut se comporter très très mal entre eux ou alors ils peuvent
à l'inverse avoir des super comportement et se tirer vers le haut et tout ça ça dépend de ce qui le entoure alors pourquoi certaines foules sont
folles et d'autres sont sages? Aucune théorie ne peut tout expliquer mais je pense qu'un nouveau champ d'étude :  la science des réseaux. Peut nous guider
son idée centrale pour comprendre les foules il ne faut pas regarder les individus mais leur
connexion
Quand on sortira cette vidéo on sera moins con si vous la quittez avant vous serez plus con que celui qui l'a pas quitté après je dis pas
ça pour vous regarder jusqu'au bout je suis pas..
En train de vous influencer de manière d'une autre.. Bon passons à la suite! Dessinons un réseau! Chaque lien représente une amitié entre deux personnes
Lui, il est copain avec lui qui est copain avec lui..
ce sont tous des amis et même eux peuvent même être copains donc du coup il ya vraiment tout le monde qui est copain avec
tout le monde nous regarde et je relis tout le monde à tout le monde c'est fou dans la vraie vie c'est jamais comme ça
vous avez forcément croisé d'époque de potes voir des potes de potes de patte de potes et on peut des fois coupé un lien entre
des individus
j'ai fait un bruit de c'est pas sorcier
c'était naturel les connexions sociales servat bien plus qu'à faire de jolies images les gens se tournent vers leurs connexions sociales pour comprendre leur monde
par exemple les gens regardent leur père pour savoir quel pourcentage de leurs amis sans se conter ce sont dix ont de gros buveurs
dessinée effacer des connexions et regardez ce qui arrive
ok donc on a un schéma avec 4 personnes 2 2 ce sont des buveurs on voit ici que lui il regarde juste lui que
lui c'est un buveur donc lui bat 100% de ses amis sont des buveurs et si on le relit je suppose à quelqu'un qui ne
boit pas hop le taux change seulement 50% des amis sont des buveurs parce qu'il a plus que lui et s'ils regardent hop le deuxième
afssa va être 33% ça c'est assez simple à comprendre mais où veux-tu en venir nikica is cependant les réseaux peuvent tromper les gens comme
la terre peut sembler plate car
J'ai fait un avc alors tout comme la terre peut sembler plate car on est dessus des gens peuvent se faire une image fausse de
la société car ils en font partie en gros dans la vraie vie c'est pas du tout aussi simple que ça mais dans la théorie
l'idée est bonne dans ce qu'ils entendent présenter par exemple une étude de
1991 a montré que presque tous les étudiants d'université ont
rapporté que leur amie buvait plus que commence la subtile et bien vous allez inventé la réponse vous même en dessinant un réseau il est
temps de tromper tout le monde c'est le moment du puzzle fait croire à tout le monde que la majorité de leurs amis sont de
gros buveurs même s'il ya deux fois moins de gros buveurs c'est vrai qu'on voit qu'il ya beaucoup plus ici de nombreux éleveurs que de
buveurs ils sont que 3 les buveurs sur un groupe de neuf personnes mais si tous les non buveurs
regarde les buveurs bas qu'est ce qui se passe
eh ben il va croire que la plupart de ses amis sont des buveurs alors que pas du tout donc là où ces gens pensent
qu'ils sont uniquement
entouré de buveurs alors qu'on voit que pas du tout c'est terrible ce que vous indiquerez s'appelle l'illusion de la majorité qui explique également pourquoi
les gens pensent que leurs idées politiques fait consensus
ou pourquoi
l'extrémiste semble plus courant qu'il ne l'est en gros c'est une question de point de vue si on regarde beaucoup plus les gens qui sont
extrémistes que les autres et ben on va avoir l'impression que la majorité est extrême et ce alors que pas du tout seulement avec les
réseaux sociaux et tout comme les extrémistes eagle énormément bas on les voit beaucoup alors je ne sont pas extrémistes eagle moins donc on les
voit moins mais les gens ne savent pas simplement passivement les idées comportement des autres îles les
copies nous allons donc maintenant regarder ce qu'on appelle les contagions j'adore
dessous nous avons une personne rouge avec un chapeau avec une information une fausse info une fête news comme on dit et tous les jours
cette personne répond la rumeur comme un vie
à ses amis qu'il à répondre à leur tour à leurs amis et ainsi de suite comme la gaffe que j'ai fait dans ma vidéo
sur la terre plate où j'ai dit que sur la lune c'était l'ombre de la terre alors que pas du tout c'est juste
sa propre ombre à la lune
j'espère voulait pas répéter à vos amis sinon je suis responsable d'une fac news malgré le non négatif les contagions peuvent être bonnes ou mauvaises
ou notes ou ambiguës
il ya une grande preuve statistique que fumer la santé la joie les motifs de vote et les niveaux de coopération sont tous
contagieux et même des preuves que les suicides et les fusillades en sont également
donc on imite bel et bien ce qui est autour de nous c'est comme ce comme les chiens aboient natsu je vois il apprendra prenant
autour de lui dessiner un réseau est lancée la simulation afin que tout le monde soit infectée par la contagion bas on voit il suffit
juste de relier d'un trait les différents groupes de personnes et ensuite le travail va se faire tout seul quoi à balancer des défèque news
la bande de salope pas bon vous rendez compte parmi un groupe de 20 personnes
il suffit juste qu'il y en ait une qui ait reçu l'information pour la réponse à tout le groupe et ensuite je vais avoir une
bonne partie du groupe qui va lui même le répandre à d'autres groupes qui vont même ça va très vite une fake news c'est terrible
cependant cette simulation fosses
à la plupart des idées ne se répande pas comme des virus pour beaucoup de croyances et de comportement il faut être exposés à la
contagion plus d'une fois pour être infecté à
il faut qu'on nous dise l'information plusieurs fois avant qu'on la vallée conte à transmettre nous mêmes c'est intéressant
les chercheurs en réseau ont trouvé une meilleure nouvelle manière de décrire comment les idées comportement se répandent
ils l'appellent les contagions
complexe maintenant 6 millions ce qui arrive quand les gens commencent à boire quand plus de 50% de leurs amis boivent avant de démarrer essayer
de deviner ce qui devrait arriver
ok donc la différence avec le premier je sais que un nom buveurs s'il a plus de 50% de ses amis qui sont buveurs il
devient lui-même buveurs d'après moi ils vont donc tous finir buveurs
ah
Non lui la deux amis autant pour moi je me suis planté sur le dernier lui comme il avait trois amis clac clac clac et
qu'un hack un des trois qui étaient buveurs qui bloque donc qui stoppe la contagion c'est un héraut constamment la présidente contagion des fausses rumeurs
cette contagion n'atteint pas tout le monde est prêt la personnes ont été infectées car bien qu'elle n'ait été face qu'à un gros buveur celui
ci représente 50% de leurs amis oui ils sont solitaires pâte en avoir deux amis c'est déjà mieux que zéro hockey
non j'ai plus jeunes en moi j'ai plus que deux amis quand même
Par contre la personne à la fin de la chaîne n'a pas été infectés car bien qu'elle était exposée à un ami gros buveurs ça
représente moins de 50% de ses amis qui sont des buveurs
cependant les contagions ne sont pas nécessairement mauvaise ici nous avons un volontaire pour je sais pas sauver des gens lors d'un ouragan
offrir des cours à des élèves en difficulté du quartier où quelque chose de cool de genre cette fois ci cependant disons que le seuil
est seulement de 25 % les gens veulent se porter volontaire mais seulement 6 25 % ou plus de leurs amis le font également alors
aux yeux de tous regardés lui je pense qu'il faut qu'ils se regardent entre eux
Oui
les contagions complexe ne sont pas nécessairement sage mais être sage et une contagion complexe
j'apprends cette notion de contagion complexe dont j'avais pas idée c'est intéressant
cette fois ci avec une contagion complexe ce sera un peu plus dur et c'est d'infecter tout le monde de sagesse complexe
en gros je peux pas juste faire ça et relié ça marchera pas on va quand même le faire pour voir mais en gros ça
va bloquer ici
Voilà ça va se transmettre le premier groupe puis ensuite lui il a trop de connections avec des gens qui n'ont pas de sagesse pour
que ça marche
alors comment on fait pour que ça marche je pense que ça doit être lui qui doivent transmettre uniquement aux trois groupes différents et là
normalement ça devrait
pas marché
ok à mon avis il faut que les groupes se passe le truc entre il faut que le mec qui te transmet le truc le
transmettre à chaque groupe et non pas uniquement au premier groupe et je raison
Oui
C'est à dire que le mec qui est sage transmet sa un groupe le groupe le transmet à un autre mais ça marche pas si
lui qu'elle a au début le transmet pas aussi bon vous dit peut-être suffit d'ajouter des connexions pour répondre une contagion complexes ou cinq bonnes
mauvaises sajoo folle mais en est-il ainsi et bien revisitons un autre puzzle précédent au
nikica et sud où travaillent les neurones mon ami si vous appuyez sur démarrer la contagion complexe va toucher tout le monde pas de surprise
cette fois ci faisant le contraire de tout ce que nous avons fait avant dessiner un réseau qui empêche la contagion d'atteindre tout le monde
bah il faut juste que tout le monde parle à tout le monde je pense est-ce que j'ai raison attention up ces sables
bien qu'un nombre important de connexions va toujours aidé à répandre des idées simples cela peut gêner le développement d'idées complexe c'est trop intéressant je
suis désolé clément thème bien répondre à un avantage non yes
les gens la nasa sont intelligents pourtant 86 malgré les avertissements des ingénieurs ils ont lancé
challenger qui a explosé tué sept personnes la raison il faisait trop froid ce jour là en fait les managers ont ignoré les avertissements des
ingénieurs pourquoi à cause de l'effet de groupe qu'un groupe est trop unis cela tend à être le cas au sommet des institutions il résiste
aux idées complexes qui met en péril leurs croyances ou leur ego les petits dessins qui vont bien que quand monde se connaît c'est beaucoup
trop unis et ça résiste beaucoup trop critique vos avis extérieur donc à gauche il n'y a pas assez de connexion et une idée ne
peut pas se propager dans le groupe ici on a le problème inverse il ya trop de connections donc on obtient une pensée de groupe
qui est très très forte et au milieu ça nous trouver un juste milieu pour pouvoir répondre une idée complexe
en gros la solution c'est que dans un groupe il faut qu'il y en ait qui ne se parlent pas je pense un
ouais c'est ça donc en gros on obtient ici des groupes dans un groupe
contrairement à la hausse et un seul groupe beaucoup trop unis et à là où il ya carrément pas de groupes c'est intéressant
peu importe comment se formuler les gens à travers les époques les cultures arrive souvent à la même conclusion une société saine nécessite un équilibre
de liens à l'intérieur de groupes et de ponts entre des groupes c'est à dire pas ça parce que les idées elles peuvent pas se
répandre
ni cela car l'effet de groupe s'ils manifesteraient donc quand quelqu'un arrive pour donner une idée bas ça passera pas mais ceux ci des groupes
emboîtés les uns dans les autres sedaka des individus qui font partie de deux groupes
différents et il est vrai ce mec là ça pour être toi tu fais partie d'un groupe ici avec tes trois autres amis mais tu
fais aussi partie de ce groupe là où il ya d'autres amis qu'on était la question du tout début pourquoi certaines poules deviennent sage et
ou folle mais oui
en résumé la folie des foules n'est pas nécessairement dû à des individus mais à comment on est piégé dans la toile qu'hollande d'un réseau
mais on ne doit pas négliger sa
responsabilité personnelle car nous sommes aussi acteur de cette toile ce que je vous disais quand vous dites ça c'est que ça a vraiment un
impact
de faire du bien autour de soi ou de faire du mal autour de soi ça a un impact beaucoup plus grand qu'on imagine donc
pour améliorer vos contagion soyez sceptiques des idées qui vous flatte prenez le temps de comprendre les idées complexes et pour améliorer vos connexions créer
des liens avec des gens aux idées proches mais aussi au delà des fossés culturels et politiques les grands triomphes et tragédies de l'histoire sont
cause et non par des gens fondamentalement bon ou mauvais mais par des gens qui sont fondamentalement des gens
neil gaiman et terry pratchett et par les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo c'est hyper intéressant
effectivement pourquoi
pourquoi il ya des groupes comme ça oubliez ça se tire vers le bas et pourquoi ya des groupes où ça se tire vers le
haut on a vraiment un impact
autour de nous on se rend pas compte même sur des trucs qui nous paraissent loin de nous sur lesquels on se dit mais non
ça sert à rien c'est un jeu facile que je fasse ça mais si mec parce que si tu lui fais les gens autour de
toi peut-être qu'ils vont le faire aussi peut-être que j'ai entendu qu'on le faire aussi était que les gens autour de vous le faire aux
tous
répercute c'est un peu l'effet boule de neige en tout cas j'ai trouvé ça hyper intéressant en passer par le site de nicaise il ya
d'autres jeux dessus et c'est vraiment hyper d un jour ça génial j'espère que ça vous aurez un peu plus la prochaine fois on sera
là pour taper des barres vous en faites pas la voilà j'avais envie juste de jouer à jeu quoi et tout jouer seul chez moi
je trouve ça cool de vous en faire profiter
n'hésitez pas à mes lèvres de ciel vous a plu si vous voulez d'autres vidéos comme ça dans les mois à venir pourquoi pas j'en
ferai peut-être une par mois une vidéo on apprend des trucs ça fait du bien un peu je trouve je fais plein de bisous je
vous dis à très vite pour des trucs un peu plus drôle pour péter en vidéo voilà tous l'inverse
jsuis horrible comment je peux faire de truc c'est différent d'une vidéo a l'autre
à très bientôt
Sous-titre fait par : les gens dans la description
<3